con la presidencia de Lula a una nueva
fase para la política exterior de
América Latina por lo que a su
investidura acudieron los principales
jefes de estado de la región con los que
Lula se reunió el martes con Gabriel
borics de chile hablaron de integración
latinoamericana con Gustavo Petro de
Colombia trataron un gran pacto
medioambiental y con Alberto Fernández
presidente de Argentina de Liderazgo
regional personalmente creo
que el presidente Lula
es un líder regional y que le va a dar
un impulso al América Latina muy
importante su presencia en Brasil es la
vuelta de Brasil a todos los foros
internacionales una nueva era de
relaciones internacionales que no se
limitan a América Latina también es
protagonista la Península ibérica con
encuentros entre Lula y el rey de España
y con el presidente de Portugal Marcelo
reveló de Sousa esperan que por fin se
firme el acuerdo entre la Unión Europea
y el mercosur tras décadas de
negociaciones el presidente Lula se ha
referido específicamente al acuerdo de
mercosur y él ya ha tomado el compromiso
de que va a ser igual que España uno de
los motores sí lo vemos más cerca la
principal economía de América Latina
vuelve a la izquierda un giro que han
experimentado las otras cuatro
principales potencias de la región dando
inicio a una nueva era después de años
de una política aislacionista llevada a
cabo por el ya expresidente Jair
bolsonaro